so you did so much for this film the
stash the styling the mississippi accent
all that stuff to take on the character
of stan what was the most difficult part
and then what was the part you relished
the most about taking on this character
um thank you for saying that
thank you for knowing it was canton
mississippi wow
um the cast really was the initial thing
and wound up you know i was just so
excited every day coming to work and
whether it was going to be willem dafoe
that day or david strathan or mark
povanelli or ron perlman or tony i mean
the cast was insane um and then being
there with guillermo
i think that was the most enjoyable
thing and then how everybody would just
sacrifice and we're willing to you mean
everybody did this for the love of the
game this was one of those movies where
every single person showed up for the
love of the game and um
yeah it was it was um it was not easy
you don't fool people stand
they fool themselves
i've given you a fortune it's time that
you delivered
when does it end
i want to know
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
[Music]
like we had seven number ones that i had
to
juggle i didn't even know how i did it
because you were not only acting you're
also producing and you were
collaborating with him so i mean he is
an icon we know that in this industry so
what was that like for you you know i've
been so lucky to work with great uh
artists and the thing that they all have
in common is a level of humility
and childlike curiosity and he has both
of those things and and the only goal is
to tell the best story possible and and
once that happens once you're in that
environment you can't help but it's
infectious and that's what he does and i
think that's why he's able to bring the
best out of most people he works with
we're very happy to see your family
arena here celebrating you tonight it's
very special yeah